I'm going to explain to you the diaper
marketing strategy that can make you
rich some retailers figured out that
every single person who has a baby
usually buys diapers you give this away
at a loss as in even less than it cost
you break even or losing money so that
you bring more people into your store
and then once they come into your store
you can sell them ancillary products
that have way more profit margin if you
have a service you itemize the list of
all the things you do and then you peel
off one of those and say hey I'm going
to make it 90% off even if you lose a
little bit of money it's okay then say
by the way aren't you going to need this
and this aren't you going to need baby
bottle aren't you going to need formula
aren't you going to need whatever you
make up the profit with way more
customers